well the effects of the pandemic still
being felt in Clark County Schools when
it comes to reading and math scores so
all
School graduation rates when it comes to
that so there is concern over a racial
graduation Gap that continues to grow
Joshua paguero was at tonight's Clark
County school board meeting and digs
deeper into the issue
while data presented by the district
shows that the high school graduation
rates still have room for improvement
when it comes to Hispanics and black
students their numbers lag in comparison
to their white and Asian counterparts
our teachers our leaders are working
really really hard and they're very
receptive to our feedback and the work
that we're doing so we look forward to
improved results in the future in the
2019-2020 school year 72 percent of
blacks and 82 percent of Hispanics
graduated high school
fast forward two school years and that
number dropped to 69 for blacks and 80
for Hispanics
Asian students are in that same year had
a 93 graduation rate while whites were
at 86 percent so how are we even coming
up district-wide with an 80 graduation
rate when more than half of our students
are not proficient they can't read they
can't do math a lot of kids fell behind
during the pandemic with covert closures
and distance learning in the 2020-2021
school year only 41 percent of students
showed Proficiency in English just 26
percent in math the graduation rate
however for ccsd's magnet Career and
Technical education schools is more than
90 percent continued investment in
advanced coursework options will better
prepare our students for future success
ccsd's High School graduation rate for
last school year was still lower than
Washoe County reporting at the Greer
education center Joshua figuero eight
news now Joshua thanks and then tomorrow
morning CCSD superintendent Dr Jesus
Jara will give his state of the school's
address that event will be live streamed
and we will cover it right here on 8
News Now